[Music]
we are
60 90 we're crossing uh 1700 so moving
right along it's good too
it's a good rating right now i think the
games are quite interesting
and uh we've had really a couple of
instructive ones and we're black here
against andre
69. let's continue our karaoke on
explorations
um i'm i'm liking the kinds of positions
we're getting in the car okay and it
goes e5 okay so that is not a move you
see every day
this move does exist i've seen it before
and it's not terrible
but we don't necessarily well
we can't play d5 here and then white is
the possibility of going d4 and
transposing to an advanced caro
but if you want to make sure that white
gets absolutely no advantage out of the
opening
you can target this pawn straight away
by playing d6 and just trading this pawn
off so d6 is
i think the simplest simplest possible
move yeah so ed6 ed6 black is not better
this is equal
but white is totally not contending for
an advantage it's a bit of a bummer
because it's a
completely dry position but so be it you
got to accept that sometimes okay so d4
we can play d5 or we can play it later
let's start by developing our knight to
f6 okay go c3
but it seems like after d5 we get a
symmetrical position where i'm basically
playing
white because i've got an extra tempo on
him so
it makes sense to go d5 open up a
pathway for the bishop to get to d6
and i think a lot of you might benefit
from a little
tutorial in playing you know i always
rant about boring positions but
it's important to be able to play them
well bishop g5
all right so how should we handle this
move
there's there's many setups that we can
choose here there's no real
correct move here there's a lot of
possibilities
uh but how should we you know what's
what are the possibilities the simplest
move is just to play bishop b7 here
as we often like to in order to
notice to remove the pin and now
if we wanted to play ambitiously we
could now act on the fact that there was
no pin and play knight e4
94 is a very good move in such positions
uh centralizing the knight forcing him
to resolve the tension
but we could play it later we could
castle first and play knight e4 later
it doesn't particularly matter we could
also play bishop g4 although
bishop g4 could be met with bishop e2
and then we get
too symmetrical of a position i want to
introduce a little bit of an
asymmetry to the position so let's play
knight e4
let's play it ambitiously
and let's see what he does
well if they take and play knight d2
then they run into a discovery could
bishop f4 okay so that's
a bit of a surprise to me i mean i was
expecting him to take on e7 but
we don't change our pattern of moves we
just castle
bishop d3 okay now that he's played
bishop d3
you see we were waiting to develop this
bishop because i wanted to see where he
put his bishop
that's often a strategy where you're
basically posturing
uh for position in this sort of subtle
way where you're trying to get your
opponent to show his cards
and then you're figuring out where to
put your pieces on the basis of that
well not bishop f5 you don't need to
defend this knight the knight is
supported by the pawn you can support it
with the other pawn if need be
but now you can play bishop g4 because
white would have to waste the tempo
dropping the bishop back to e2
and this creates a little bit of tension
in white's position it's not not a big
deal we're not better
but you know we're beginning to annoy
him just a little bit
because a lot of people don't like to to
return to e2 and make the same you know
make two moves with one piece
although bishop e2 would be you know
perhaps the most cautious move for white
here
now on the next move we need to complete
our development the knight goes to d7 in
such positions
and we could uh imagine that the knight
could later go to f6
supporting the e4 knight although most
likely it's just going to remain on d7
for the time being just making sure that
his knight never gets a chance
uh to reach the e5 square uncontested
can't they just stick with the queen
though well we're not planning to take
the knight
we're just putting pressure on his
position what we're essentially doing
we're pinning the knight to the queen so
if the queen ever moves aside then we'll
be able to take the knight and ruin his
pawn structure
in such positions you can't do
everything at once you have to gradually
build up the pressure very patiently
you know inch by inch by degrees and
eventually
uh if you annoy your opponent enough or
if you create enough small problems
these small problems
uh coalesce into bigger ones so knight
d7 of course
and again we have in in reserve the move
f5
which uh will only really be necessary
if he puts more pressure on the knight
and there comes queen b3 there comes the
mistake
so he immediately loses his patience and
obviously the reason we played bishop g4
is so that we could take the knight
precisely in this situation
now my guess is that he saw this and
assumed
that we wouldn't be able to take on f3
because now he's attacking b7 and he's
attacking the knight simultaneously now
for the record
even if we had to sacrifice the pawn on
v7 i still would not mind
we still would go for this it would
probably be worth the pawn sacrifice but
we don't have to
and there's many reasons why not
what's the simplest move where can we
put bring the knight so that the pawn on
b7 is defended
okay so we can play knight d6 and it's
very important to establish
that if he takes on d6 and then takes on
b7 he's left his king completely wide
open
and how can we punish uh how can we
deliver checkmate in the most efficient
manner if he does that just to make sure
that we're on the same page there
yeah queen h4 or even queen g5 and queen
f4 building up the battery
that's obviously going to result in
checkmate so we just drop our knight
back to d6
now you wouldn't you don't necessarily
have to see that even when you're
playing knight d6 you can just see that
by taking on d6 he's leaving his king
wide open he's not going to do that
that's not a mistake that people in the
60s oh well i guess it is a mistake that
people in the 1600 range could make
um i jinxed him yeah that's strange i
mean
he seems to be oblivious to the threat
that lies
uh that's staring at him right in the
face so
[Music]
all right so let's find let's find the
fastest checkmate
let's find the fastest checkmate and
it's not queen h4
queen h4 is the most tempting move but
people often forget that one way of
defending
against the mape threat is to move the
rook aside
and open up a little escape pathway for
the king which doesn't
you know that doesn't save white in the
long term but what you can start with is
queen g5 check you drive the king
further into the corner and then either
queen h4
or even better queen f4 creating the
battery and leading to imminent
checkmate
queen f4 is the most clinical move boom
boom
and queen takes h2 mate
yeah this check first is often missed by
people driving the king into the corner
first
uh and and sometimes that contains a lot
more importance than it does here here
everything wins
okay yeah well i just think he he didn't
see the bigger picture he didn't
recognize
how weak his king was so
yeah that escalated quickly okay so e5
is
e5 is not terrible and i think d6 is
probably the best way to respond to it
takes takes okay d4 knight f6 okay c3
is fine yeah bishop g5 is fine
yeah so if i was playing white
i would suggest starting with knight d2
so that we don't have the
or so that knight e4 isn't as strong and
then playing knight f3 and bishop d3
this is dead equal
thank you sn and th that's a great point
um
simon and same with h3 you're absolutely
right that's literally the fastest mate
thank you
for the two gifted okay so this would be
a little bit more
precise knight f394 and now i would take
on e7 i'm not sure why he tried to be
cool and go like bishop f4
because he ended up in a very passive
position just take on e7
queen e7 bishop e2 still equal but i
would definitely take black here i mean
you know it's it's equal but black is
maybe a tiny bit more comfortable here
so that's one way that we could have
rolled out our development he played
bishop f4 and again we castle
ah he goes bishop d3 and only now did we
develop our bishop to g4
because if he had developed his bishop
to e2 then we probably would have
occupied f5
okay so it's like it depends where he
puts his bishop and
in accordance with that we choose where
to develop ours
um if that makes sense because bishop g4
after bishop e2
would not be nearly as effective and it
might walk into the exact same thing
that we did to him which is 95.
that kind of plays into his hands
all right so bishop d3 bishop g4
castle's knight t7 and things really
haven't reached
a crisis point here but he panics with
queen b3
now what should white do here well the
situation i think already
calls for just dropping the bishop back
to e2
and immediately dealing with this pin
because the more
time we have to accumulate the pressure
the worse it becomes for white if white
plays
one more nonchalant move such as
rookie one well rookie one might not be
so bad we would meet that with that with
f5 cementing the knight on e4 and
you know now it's a little bit harder
for white to deal with the pressure
h3 whoops sorry h3 we would go
bishop h5 h3 is not a problem h3 just
bishop h5 and we are fine
um i mean g4 is
obviously way too weakening we can then
play f5 and just
make his king side explode is bishop g5
bad where well bishop g5 doesn't really
work we just take the bishop
so not sure which position you're
referring to but queen b3
we obviously take and go knight to d6
why is g4 weakening
if his black bishop is still up um
well it's weakening because he advances
pawns
in front of his own king and
um and that's weakening regardless of
the pieces that he has left
and in addition it creates a hook on g4
a hook is a pawn that's
uh advanced pat's past its initial
square
and we can use this hook to open up
files for our rook in particular we
could follow this with f5
and try to take on g4 and open up the
rook's
uh pathway and then his pieces are going
to get incredibly vulnerable also note
that when you play the move g4
now the knight is no longer protected by
a pawn and that becomes very important
when the f file is open that knight
could get caught up in some sort of a
fork or a skewer
stuff like that would g4 be good if he
hasn't castled it no
so i guess what you're asking is is this
a better idea than it is when he's
castled
marginally because maybe he'll castle
queenside
but the problem is that when he plays c3
he
he weakens his queen side as well and i
don't really see a way for him
to efficiently organize queenside castle
so this is way too committal
it burns all the bridges and even with
this king in the center it's still very
weakening
opening up the f-file is still very good
for black
so i wouldn't recommend this under any
circumstances
in general playing h3 g4 is something
that you do
there there are situations when you're
castled
and when it is acceptable to play hbg4
but this is not one of them and there
are also situations when your king is in
the center but you know for a fact that
you're going to castle the other way
and when you know that then you can do
basically whatever the hell you want on
the side that you're not castling on
now to give you a very simple example of
a position where you would play
um h3 g4 and then castle
there's a set of subtle differences that
um you know that that often allow you
to play h6 and g5 or h3 and g4 when
you're already castled
so let me give you an example okay
so this is just a random italian kind of
position
and let's assume that it's white to move
like in this position playing h3
followed by g4
would be very much acceptable and
the reason why first of all is that
if you compare that to the position we
were just looking at this pawn cannot be
as easily exploited
in the game position we had the idea of
going f5 to open the file clearly that
is not applicable here because there's
another pawn on e4 and the knight is
in the way it's just not practical and
the secondary thing is that black's
pieces are kind of clogged up
and it's just not as easy uh to approach
white's king in any way this bishop on
g5 is a really nice piece it's
immobilizing the knight
it's creating a pin of white zone so
just from the point of view of trying to
get an attack started it's a lot harder
to do that here than it is there
and this pin that the bishop is exerting
over the night is very now is very very
hard
uh to deal with because after h6 bishop
h4 the bishop on g6 is blocking
black's ability to go g5 and this bishop
cannot drop back to e7 because there's a
pawn on d6
so you can see the specific factors in
the position dictate
whether you're able to get away with
something like this there's no easy
answer here
you have to look at each position
individually and ask yourself does my
opponent have the capacity
to exploit these weaknesses that i'm
making and that can be
a hard question to answer
okay well i can extend on the queen side
white can continue on the king side too
so i can give you an example for one of
my games actually let me
let me see if i can find one of my games
where i played h3g4 when i castled then
i'll show you how i was able to okay
actually no nah this is not a good not a
good game
yeah let's just go back to that position
um
i'm not an expert in these italian
positions so take this with a grain of
salt
basically one idea would be to expand on
the queen side that's sort of
something you could do independent of
whatever your plan is
you know you could have b4 a4 just
pressuring black on the queen side maybe
b5
um another idea would be in very typical
rye lopez in italian fashion to go
rookie one and then follow it up with
knight f193 or knight g3
then trying to get the knight to d5 to
pressure the f6 knight or maybe to f5
so that's another idea and a third idea
could be
uh believe it or not to actually attack
on the king side so you could try to
move your king aside to h1 and go rook
g1
and and and use these pawns and pawn
storm g5
and the knight g5 and you have an
abundance of pieces on the king side so
just because
your king is also on the king side
doesn't
exclude you uh from attacking on that
side of the board you're gonna have to
be very careful uh
to make sure your king doesn't get
caught in the crossfire but
you can still very much attack black's
king here and that's something which a
lot of people just assume is impossible
if you're castle to the king side well
then you can't push the pawns on that
same side of the board you absolutely
can
you just gotta do it with a lot of
caution uh but
just because white's king is a little
bit exposed doesn't mean
you just automatically can't attack on
that side
it looks risky but where is black's
attack going to come from black has no
pieces
that are currently capable of even
approaching white's king
white's queen is going to come out to f3
black's gonna get checkmated here
pretty straightforwardly double rooks on
the g file exactly
is h3 without g4 a good idea yes h3
without g4 is usually a good idea just
to create luft
to tickle the bishop and to be able to
play g4 later
f4 against the caro you can play d5
e5 bishop f5 just like against the
advance
um what's the best response to a pawn
storm without pieces backing them up
well that's a bit of a general question
and it really
depends sometimes pawn storms create
weaknesses that you want to occupy
and sometimes you know uh
if a pawn storm weakens your opponent's
king then you know you want to exploit
the weaknesses that are created
so i can give you an example of an
instance
where my opponent played h6 g5 on the
same side that he castle it and it
backfired
he shouldn't have done it and i can show
you how i was able to exploit it
if people are are interested and this is
slightly off topic but i think to to
your question
so this is a game i played in 2011 i was
in i am
this is a sort of a typical rye lopez
sort of like the position we just saw
has certain similarities and here i came
up with an interesting idea
i played the move knight a3 so
my idea was to get the knight involved
to e3 but in a very unconventional way
usually
the way that you do it is you play
knight bd2 and then rookie one and then
knight f1 but i found in this particular
case a more efficient way to do it i
play knight a3
than knight c2 then 93. but my so my
opponent goes h6 bishop h4 bishop g4
i go knight c2 i mean i'm still going to
e3 and he goes g5
okay so bishop g3 and knight to h5
trying to get his own knight
perhaps to f4 and what i was able to do
here is kind of trick my opponent
into exposing his king even further i
played 90 whoops i played knight e3
okay so this attacks the bishop on g4
and forces it to decide
the problem for black is that it well
taking my knight is
horrible because look at these holes on
the light squares that have been created
so that's unthinkable right uh
moving the bishop if i'm calculating it
correctly falls into a very typical
tactic in these types of positions who
can spot
the tactic that i'm referring to and as
you're thinking i'm gonna go
for some more tea
just give me a minute guys
uh i have arrived yet knight takes c5 is
correct
loose pieces drop off but wait a minute
black can take on g3
and if we take the knight then we lose
the knight but no as i'm sure many of
you correctly understood
intermediate move you take the knight
attack the queen black has to take
you take and now white is up a pawn and
black
black's king side is full of holes and
queen is coming out to h5 and the game
is basically over
okay so
my opponent is kind of stuck and he's
forced to take the knight
and after f6 e3 i've got kind of good
doubled pawns that control all these
squares and guess what i've got the f
file for my rook
now he decided to also take my bishop
and i take back
and now he drops the bishop to e6 which
makes sense i mean this bishop on b3 is
a very strong bishop it's
you know it's x-raying the king and
stuff so he decides to trade it
uh but i don't need to react to this
move because my queen is defending my
bishop so in principle if i found
if i had found a good move i don't
necessarily need to trade bishops in
fact it's a very bad idea to trade
bishops
because he's going to take back with
what and this is very instructive
so what is he going to take back with
he's going to take back with a pawn and
this is very bad for white because this
opens up a line of negotiation between
the rooks
and now you're hamstrung because if you
move the knight aside to try to get the
queen to h5
you allow a trade of rooks and the more
black trades the less
pronounced the weaknesses become i hope
that makes sense also the f5 square
which hey guess what maybe this night
this this square could be occupied by
the night one day
uh is no longer a weakness
so that was out of the question and i
started to think okay
well clearly in playing h6 g5 black has
exposed himself on the light squares in
particular what two squares
seem to be the weakest among all of the
light squares on the king
side what are the two squares where the
party seems to be at
but is so his king is more open
is a relative thing right yes
technically his king is more open but
again i've come back
to this condom what are you going to
exploit that with you don't have the
the tools necessary to exploit the fact
that the king is more open simply the
fact that the king is more open is not a
reason not to play a move that makes
sense
h5 and f5 is correct so i thought okay
and i love this kind of backward
reasoning
i want to occupy both of those squares
at some point
now which pieces seem poised to occupy
those squares well you can
already imagine the queen going to h5
and thank you uh stow production and you
can imagine perhaps the rook going to f5
after the bishop if we can
get black uh to trade on our terms then
the rook will come to f5 and then we can
double rooks
now that first of all leaves the knight
and when i give this problem
when i gave this position to my students
a lot of them
suggested the move knight to d2 which is
quite a sensible move
and the idea is that after bishop takes
b3 you play knight takes b3 so you don't
distract the queen
the queen comes to h5 and the row comes
to f5 but my criticism of this is that
well what about the knight
the knight seems to be stranded on b3
and it wants to join the party
so in what way can we get the knight to
join the party
as many of you are suggesting you can
play knight h2 and that is in fact what
i played
and it's an inaccuracy but it's almost
correct
so my ideal position
arose in the game so my opponent took on
b3
he played queen e6 and now the reason it
was an inaccuracy is just because it's a
little bit inefficient
queen back to d1 queen to h5
and if i had found a way to not spend so
many tempe
on moving my queen back and forth i
would have already been able to put my
rook on f5 and put my knight on too far
that was the ideal setup that i was
aiming for rook on f5
whoops nope and night on g4 now all
three pieces
are in the party and just massaging
black terrorizing black i should say on
these light squares right
but um what i had not
realized is that i do have a way of
accomplishing this plan more efficiently
and i see the correct move simply
slipped my mind
so rather than trading on e6 there's an
intermediate square that i could go to
what move am i talking about
it's a really really uh powerful
positional move and it shows a deep
understanding of the position
mailman he's got it
bishop to d5 yes this is the classic
application of trading on your own terms
you're basically telling black either
take my bishop
and then not only do you get all of this
stuff but now blacks knight is also
has to move back and destroy the
connection between the rooks and give
ypa file on top of everything else and
you can still go knight h2
and queen h5 but if black doesn't take
and moves the knight then you've you've
washed your hands of the need to keep
this to babysit the bishop
why could gonna h2 and this bishop is
perfectly good on c6
and um the funny thing is if
c6 then you can already take the bishop
on e6 because
since the connection between the rooks
has been destroyed
now i can get away with taking and going
queen h5 and black is just
totally overwhelmed here as the knight
comes to g4 this is a brilliant
positional move
i missed it i played knight h2 which is
the next best thing
but you can kind of see the logic
building up on top of each other
like first we find where our pieces
belong we understand that we want to use
the light squares
we come up with a target setup and then
that final step
is figuring out the most efficient way
of bringing that setup about
so there's a lot of steps here but
um but but you know if you can
go through all of those steps you're
able to produce nice moves
all right uh and i managed to win the
game i ultimately outplayed him i mean
i attacked him from all sides i won a
pawn and then
and then ultimately i won this end game
all right i'm glad to hear people
enjoyed that but let's move to the next
game
so back to the speedrun game nothing
worthwhile happened after queen b3 mna
explained this after the game
during the game yeah he took on d6 that
loses immediately
white should just develop the knight to
d2 and white is still very much alive
the bishop could drop back to g3 to lend
some support to the king
but taking on d6 is just very
short-sighted and and yeah this one's
the game
and yes as simon indicated this is more
this is less efficient technically
because white can prolong the game by
one more move
so queen f4 is not only more clinical
but
literally more efficient
[Music]
you